[Musique]
acteur de proximité privilégiée auprès
des communes le conseil départemental
investi dans les territoires après
quelques années de difficultés
budgétaires les finances du département
se porte mieux pour l'année 2019 le
budget d'investissement est doublé au
total 112 millions d'euros dont une
partie sera allouée à l'investissement
dans les grandes missions du département
dans le cadre des investissements
propres et bien l'une de nos priorités
c'est d'investir pour les jeunes en
l'occurrence les collèges
nous sommes là devant le collège de
fortschwihr et ce sont sur les dix
prochaines années
160 millions d'euros que le conseil
départemental va mettre dans la
rénovation dans l'extension de collèges
voir dans la construction aussi de
nouveaux collèges donc les collèges les
routes qui est un domaine très important
pour le conseil départemental est donc
cette année 7 6 un budget qui a été
augmentée de d'un tiers pour les routes
et qui se montait cette année à 51
millions d'euros mais également des
investissements dans les ehpad
ce sont 8 millions d'euros qui sont
dégagés pour la rénovation des ehpad et
aussi 2 millions d'euros pour le
maintien à domicile des personnes âgées
qui pour soutenir les projets des
communes des intercommunalités mais
aussi des associations
un nouveau fonds vient d'être créé et
doté de 12 millions d'euros sur les
trois prochaines années
c'est un fonds territorial
d'investissement de 12 millions d'euros
sur les trois prochaines années pour
permettre et bien aux communes et aux
associations de mettre en place les
projets qui sont les leurs et dans les
territoires
c'est à dire que nous avons une manière
de fonctionner sur ce crédit qui est que
de faire remonter des projets des
territoires et c'est à l'échelle du
territoire que le choix des priorités se
fait
si les budgets de ces dernières années
était contraint le département n'a pas
pour autant cessé d'investir dans les
territoires en témoignent les
réalisations effectuées dans le canton
de colmar 2 l'institution est intervenu
en soutien de nombreux projets communaux
et malgré les contraintes aux difficiles
que nous avons connus ces dernières
années le département est resté très
actif par exemple à colmar nous sommes
un nous sommes intervenus pour la
rénovation la mise à niveau du parc des
expositions
nous étions également dans le domaine du
sport présent aqualia mais également
pour les plus petits clubs où nous avons
affecté
six cent mille euros au cours des trois
dernières années pour la rénovation par
exemple de terrain de football à
holtzwihr port du ried à houssen pour
des terrains
pour des terrains d'activités divers
dans différentes communes
on est aussi allé dans la direction de
la petite enfance par exemple la maison
de la famille à colmar dont nous avons
financer la restructuration nous sommes
également présents dans le domaine
routier évidemment où on fait des
traverse d'agglomération et des travaux
qui sont très souvent initiées par les
communes mais le développement du
territoire ne passe pas que par le
soutien aux seuls projets des communes
le déploiement du très haut débit par
exemple reçoit le soutien du département
est un facteur important pour
l'attractivité des communes notamment
rurales les investissements dans les
infrastructures comme les collèges et
les ehpad sont eux aussi importants pour
la qualité de vie des habitants
on a des demandes fortes en matière de
dépendance personnes âgées un certain de
cette un secteur d'activité où on n'a
jamais lésiné on a toujours maintenu des
financements au niveau qui correspondait
aux besoins qui existent sur le
territoire
ensuite la jeunesse vous voyez le
collège de fortschwihr qui a été relevé
au cours des dernières années on a
investi 7 millions d'euros quasiment
pour le mettre à niveau
mais à d'autres collèges qui ont
également bénéficié de ce type de
soutien comme le collège victor hugo par
exemple qui se trouvent dans notre
secteur où le collège berlioz qu'on
connaît tous et qui tend collège 19 et
qui permet aux jeunes d'être jeune
collégien d'être accueillis dans les
meilleures conditions
mais les financements ne font pas tout
le département se positionne aussi en
partenaires des autres collectivités
pour les aider à porter leurs projets il
y a aussi des aides en ingénierie qui
sont proposés par le département aux
communautés de communes aux communes
mais également au public dans le domaine
de l'économie avec la dira dans le com
domaine de l'aménagement du territoire
et de l'urbanisme avec l'as d'or dans le
domaine du tourisme avec alsace
destination tourisme et puis dans le
domaine de l'habitat et du logement avec
l'adil notre leitmotiv c'est la
proximité l'efficacité et la citoyenneté
pour le contre colmar d un certain
nombre de projets d'ores et déjà pour
les tuyaux par exemple les murs
antibruit à houssen qui devrait bientôt
être rénové coût de l'opération des
100000 euros et il ya un certain nombre
de projets notamment à colmar comme le
projet de rénovation de la bibliothèque
des dominicains sur lequel ne seront
évidemment présents il y à l'aspect
routier évidemment vous avez par exemple
avoue design qui est à côté
la traverse d'agglomération on va
investir également plus de 100000 euros
ce qui nous guide avant tout c'est la
logique de de la proximité que les
services publics soient toujours à la
proximité des habitants c'est une
logique aussi d'équité et d'équilibré
entre les territoires en 2021 le
département du haut-rhin se fondra dans
la collectivité européenne d'alsace la
nouvelle échelle sera dont celle de
l'entièreté du territoire alsacien mais
le département on l'a sur la proximité
ne sera pas sacrifiée donc demain
cette proximité avec la collective
européenne d'alsace sera toujours là
efficacité efficacité parce que ça c'est
vraiment l'un des maîtres mots
aujourd'hui déjà pour le département
mais demain aussi efficacité grâce à la
proximité grâce au pragmatisme des
conseillers départementaux et grâce à
une faculté d'agir très rapide
baa